tenemos que f de 7 es igual a 45 elevado
a la séptima potencia y f prima de x es
igual a 5 a la equis y nos preguntan
cuánto vale efe de 0 así que para
obtener efe de cero lo que vamos a hacer
es tomarnos la anti derivada de f prima
de x y de ahí vamos a obtener una
constante de integración entonces
podemos usar la información que nos dan
justo aquí que f de 7 es igual a esto lo
cual es una expresión bien bueno es una
expresión pero realmente es un número no
hay variables en esto entonces podemos
usarlo para resolver esa constante de
integración y después ya tendremos
completamente a fx y así vamos a poder
utilizar a esa fx para evaluar efe de 0
entonces hagámoslo si f prima de x es
igual a 5 a la x entonces fx fx va a ser
igual a la anti derivada de esto es
igual a la anti derivada
elevado a la equis
y bueno una propiedad que encuentro
interesante de las exponenciales
de hecho permítanme primero voy a hacer
un paso antes de decirte esa propiedad
voy a sacar este 5 afuera de la integral
y me va a quedar 5 veces la anti
derivada de un elevado a la x de x y una
de las propiedades muy interesantes que
me parecen de la función exponencial es
que la anti derivada de la x es l x y
bueno eso porque la derivada de x es x
lo que encuentro increíble cada vez que
tengo que pensar o manipular la derivada
o la anti derivada de la x entonces esto
de aquí va a ser exactamente igual que 5
veces
elevado a la equis más una constante de
integración y lo puedes comprobar
sacando la derivada de 5 a la equis más
la derivada de 5 e a la equis bueno eso
es 5x así que vamos bien y la derivada
de c es cero porque es una constante así
que no la vamos a ver aquí y llegamos
justo a esto ahora qué te parece se
utilizó esta información que tengo aquí
para determinar el valor de la constante
el valor de sem y ya que sepamos quién
es él
vamos a saber exactamente cuánto es efe
de equis y ya que tenemos a fx vamos a
evaluarla en cero para obtener la
respuesta que estamos buscando así que
sabemos que f de 7 déjame ponerlo con
este color
efe de 7 esto va a ser igual am y bueno
vamos a sustituir a x por 7 me va a
quedar 5
elevado a la séptima potencia más ce ok
pero por otra parte sabemos que f de 7
es esto que tengo aquí es 40 40
+ 5 elevado a la séptima potencia así
que f de 7 es esta información que tengo
aquí y también esto que tengo aquí y ya
con esto es bastante sencillo obtener
asem porque si eliminamos a 5 y a las 7
de ambos lados voy a obtener que éste va
a ser igual a 40 de luz entonces ya
podemos escribir de nuevo a efe de x fx
va a ser igual a 5m elevado a la x más
se pero se vale 40 y ahora sí si
queremos obtener el valor df de cero
podemos decir que f de cero va a ser
igual a cinco
elevado a la potencia 0 + 40 pero he
elevado la potencia 0 esto es 1 así que
me quedarían cinco por uno los cuales 5
+ 40 es 45
y ya con esto hemos terminado